[Applause]
what's next all right well the
huffington post is asking is it time to
end the shapewear era because it has
been a big business since spanx arrived
in the early 2000s changing the game and
then following a long tradition of like
you know we used to have girdles and
corsets yeah this did you know what i
love
that
fact because we have been
pulling at ourselves for centuries
remember that scene in titanic where
she's just like oh
my god her angry mother for everyone yes
i know
yeah yeah we know
well uh some women are swearing off
shapewear for good now they say it feeds
into old sexist ideas about beauty it
keeps people from loving and accepting
their bodies and bottom line truth it's
just uncomfortable to walk around like a
stosh stuffed sausage all day
i'm doing that regardless
have you ever worn you won the spanx
before that refuse and i do think that
for women there is an empowerment too it
does help the clothes fall better
um i don't mind looking like the
michelin man i i'm like here is my role
i can't handle that type of constriction
um
i uh i remember after i gave birth to
the girls you can get diastasis
diastasis it's where your like stomach
separates permanently so they make you
want to put this thing on oh i know whoa
kiss your mothers
and they make you want to put this thing
on so that it actually like comes back
together sometimes it doesn't
the the girdle was worse than the
pregnancy i just like i don't care
i hate being constricted um i put on a
man spank one time one time one time i
felt like i felt like i did something
wrong it was like
like i was being punished but you know
my friends i have friends who love
wearing it because of how it makes them
feel yep and i think at the end of the
day that's what it should be it's it's
you shouldn't feel the pressure to wear
it because you are perfect as it is
gonna feel pressure that's the whole
point right um you're gonna feel your
liver
argument
you wear it you like it you don't like
it you don't wear it i mean i had this
thing actually where we did this thing i
put it out on the social for the show um
i made my own version
of a sort of um
well check it out
i've been eating my stress
a little bit lately and i have to have
like a brazier thing
put in there
so i'm gonna reevaluate my life this
weekend
so you're brilliant so i guess i'm more
for expanders
than tighteners
i'm a fluctuator and i just kind of try
to go with it sometimes i'm really
stressed and food is my comfort
sometimes i put work first
and i leave myself in the dust right now
is one of those times sometimes i have a
little more time to myself and i find a
better balance and i feel really good
but then i lose sight of it and if
anybody else is on this roller coaster i
really relate to you because that is the
one i've been on my whole life totally i
don't recommend it
but i relate if i ever and i'm saying
this right now if or when i ever run for
high office president whatever i'll vote
for you you'll go free well my platform
will be all pants must be elastic pants
thank you so much
and i will stick to that i was already
gonna vote for you now i'm definitely
voting thank you well
um
what we put on uh matters and finally uh
that leads me into my latest pick for
drew's little yellow book my curated
list that i love to share with you thank
you every
so today's pick is something from our
brand my brand flower beauty but it's in
collaboration with sharon shooter sharon
shooter is the creator also of oma
beauty one of the best beauty brands out
there on the market but she did a thing
called pull up for change where she
demanded companies sort of do all black
packaging it's part of the make it black
campaign where 100 of the net proceeds
will go to pull up for the change fund
which directly supports black
black-owned businesses and founders so
thank you sharon shooter for always
making all of us better
and to kick off black history month
thank you for making us all do things
differently better and in your honor uh
you're amazing thank you so much
fantastic drew
and this is our flower beauty winged
liner so get it while it's hot we'll be
right back
[Music]
you